المترجم: Salma Madani
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
أحبتى هناك العديد من الظواهر والقدرات
يمكن عدها خارقة للطبيعة البشرية؛
كالتخاطر
والمعرفة المسبقة
والاستبصار
أو بالأحرى تليباثى،
و Precognition [البصيرة]
وأنا أعني فى الحقيقة Precast [التنبؤ]
لأن precognition ليس هو موضوعنا.
و أيضا Clairvoyancy [الجلاء البصري].
كل ذلك يعد من الباراسيكولوجي.
فهل يا ترى هذه القدرات
تقع ضمن الدجل والسحر؟
أو الاستعانة بالجان؟
هنا عندي وقفة من الضرورى أن أتكلم عنها.
وهى أنه يؤلمنا جدا
- نحن جماعة الباراسيكولوجى -
أن يكون المشعوذين أو الدجالين
أو العرافين.
والذين لا يعرفون أساسا
معنى كلمة باراسيكولوجي.
أو حتى طريقة لفظها.
فتجد الإشفائى الباراسيكولوجى،
الكذا الباراسيكولوجى.
يقحمون كلمة الباراسيكولوجي في كل شيء.
ولهذا كان كثيرا ممن يروني يقولون
"هل ستطالع لنا المستقبل؟"
و أظل افكر عمَّ يتحدث!
و أقول هل تمزح معي؟!
(ضحك)
وهم يربطون ذلك
بالقضايا الدينية والقرآن وإلى آخره.
كل هذا يؤلمني.
على كلٍّ فإن
الدراسات المتعلقة بالأنثروبولوجي
أو علم الإنسان؛
إذ أن هناك تأكيد لأكثر من دراسة
تقول أن الإنسان القديم في العصر الحجري،
أو في العصور القديمة
كان عنده عدد من قدرات الباراسيكولوجي.
وهذا يعني أنه كان بإمكانه
أن يتكلم مع المادة.
أي أنه كانت هناك روابط عقلية مع المادة.
روابط تدخل في العقل وتأثيره على المادة.
وقد يكون بإمكانه أن يسقط صخرة على بعد،
إذا ما داهمه خطر معين.
لكن بمرور الزمن
أصبح لا يمكنه أن ينتظر الصخرة إلى أن تقع،
أو ينظر بعينه نحو حيوان فيصبح جاهزا للأكل،
فبدأ يعتمد على الآلة.
بدأ ينحت الصخور ويحولها إلى سلاح،
على الأقل يحمي نفسه.
بمرور الزمن ومع مرور آلاف السنين؛
توارت هذه القدرات.
أو فلنقول أنه تراكم عليها التراب.
متى تظهر؟
قد تظهر في حالات معينة لكتير من الناس.
بل حتى الأن أنتم بأكملكم
عندكم على الأقل واحدة منها.
لو كنت مثلا مطرقا وفجأة
خطر على بالك زميل
لم تره منذ سنوات،
وفجأة دق الباب ووجدته أمام عينيك،
أو رن الهاتف ووجدته هذا الصيق،
وأنت لم تره منذ زمن.
كما يقول المثل "ابن الحلال بذكره يبان".
وأولها أن معظم من توقعوا الحضور
من أحبتي الحضور هم بأكملهم هكذا.
أي أنهم بالتأكيد عندهم ما ذكرته في المثال.
على كلٍّ؛
خلال مرحلة الثانوية والمتوسطة
كان والدي رحمه الله هو صديقي وأستاذي أيضا.
وكنت متأثرًا بكثيرٍ من الفلاسفة؛
لاسيما العلميين منهم مثل أينشتاين ونيوتن
وأخرين بالتأكيد.
فسألت والدي السؤال الآتي:
إذا افترضنا أننا مددنا خطين متوازيين،
أو فلنقول "شعاعين متوازيين".
هذه الصورة تعمدت أن أجعلها صورة كونية،
تبدوكأنها مُلتقَطة من الفضاء الخارجي.
ماذا نقصد بهذه الصورة؟
أن هذين االشعاعين
يمتدان إلى اللا ليميت؛
أي بدون محدودية.
الآن السؤال:
إذا ثبتنا أحد هذين الشعاعين، فلنأخذ مثلا
الشعاع اليمين
إذا ثبتنا هذا الشعاع اليمين
وطلبنا من الشعاع اليسار أن ينحرف
انحرافًا بأقل درجة زاويةٍ ممكنة،
سيتقاطعان بالتأكيد.
الآن: ما هي أصغر زاوية نحرك بها
الشعاع اليسار حتى يتقاطع مع الشعاع اليمين؟
ما هي أصغر زاوية، كم تكون مثلا؟
عشرة أس ناقص ثلاثة من الدرجات؟
أم عشرة أس ناقص ثلاثة آلاف من الدرجات؟
أم ماذا؟
مثلا عشرة أس ناقص ستة وخمسين من الدرجات؟
قد تقول صفر، أنا أحب الصفر.
على كلٍّ، هذا السؤال نفسه
سألته في الجامعة.
أديسون نفسه (أبو الإنتجريشن)
سألته نفس السؤال.
وفال لي "أنظر يا معروف
ليس بإمكاني أن أعطيك أية إجابة،
لكن يمكن القول أن هناك إطار آخر
ننتقل إليه،
أي ممكن أن انتقل إلى عالم آخر
أو بعدٍ آخر".
وذلك أفادنى نوعا ما، لكنه لم يقدم
لي أية إجابة.
لكن هذه الأمور كانت دائما تخطر على بالي.
وحتى الآن أتسائل ما هو الصفر؟
إذا كانت عندي مسافة متر وجزأتها إلى نصفين،
وأجزِّئ النصف إلى نصفين وأظل أجَزِّئ.
واستمر في التجزئة.
أي مسافة أجزئها إلى نصفين
وأستمر فى النزول،
إلى أين ننتهي؟
نقسم الذرِّة وننزل من ذرة إلى ذرة.
حتى نصل إلى 102 جسيم من الذرَّة،
واستمر في التقسيم. إلى أين ستصل؟
هدفي بالطبع أن أصل إلى الصفر.
فهل أصل هناك؟
لا
إذًا ماذا يحدث؟
نحن في الحقيقة مبرمجين أن نقع بين الصفر،
بل لا يمكننى أن أقول "بين الصفر"،
لأننى لم أتمكن من تحديد مكان الصفر.
أو حتى المالانهاية
فنحن أكبر من الصفر وأقل من المالانهاية.
نحن مبرمجين أن نعيش بين هذين العالمين فقط.
أو لا يوجد مكان آخر.
مثلا رجل يقف على بعد، ينظر خلف حاجز معين
يستطيع أن يرى خلفه.
كيف نفسر ذلك؟
أو يركز بنظره على بعض الأوراق
- وأنا رأيت تجربة بعيني -
تلك الفتاة الهندية التى ركزت نظرها
على ورقة.
وذلك أخذ منها حوالى 28 دقيقة،
لكن الورقة فى النهاية احترفت في الوسط.
حيث ركزت بمركز الورقة، وأتذكر حينها
أنها خسرت من وزنها حوالى كيلو ونصف.
حدث ذلك أمامي.
وأمثلة على ذلك أيضا مثل لَيّ المعادن
والاستبصار
وكتير من ظواهر الباراسيكولوجي
فكنت دائما أبحث عن حل من أجل
إيجاد آلية شاملة لكل الباراسيكولوجي.
وقسم منها أشياء دينية مثلا
كالإسراء والمعراج.
لابد أن يكون هناك ذلك النظام الذي يحوي
ميكانيزم [آلية] معينة،
كي يخلصني من هذه الإشكالات
بالكامل دفعة واحدة.
حاولت كثيرًا
أمضيت 3 عقود من التفكير، وأعتقد أخيرًا
أنني توصلت إلى شيء.
وإن شاء الله أكون محقًا.
أن يكون هناك يومًا ما عالم
جديد من الفيزياء، وإلى آخره.
مشكلتنا هي في الحقيقة مع الزمن؛
افترض أن هناك زمنًا آخر.
لا أقول "الزمن الآخر"، ولكن أقول
"زمنًا آخر" أي زمن رقم 2.
الذي يوجد معنا دائما
وهو عمودي على زمننا.
من أين أتى زمننا؟
ما هو الزمن؟
وهو كما سماه أينشتاين"البعد الرابع".
هو في الحقيقة حركة المكان
فمتى تحرك المكان أو الجسم،
يكون هذا المسار الذي يصنعه هو فى الأساس
بعد زمني.
حتى لو كان لا يتحرك، فقط جامد فوق المنضدة.
بمرور الزمن عليه،
بكلمة مرور الزمن أعني أنه دائما في حركة .
هو مستقر نسبيا، لكنه دائما في حركة.
ما يهمني هو أن التوصل إلى أن البعد الرابع
هو البعد الزمني.
الآن جاء معروف الجبلي يتفلسف (مزحة)
يقول أن هناك بعد ثانٍ للزمن؛
البعد الخامس.
وكيف ظهر البعد الخامس؟
مثلما ظهر البعد الرابع،
أي من حركة 3 أبعاد مكانية.
نحن عندنا 3 أبعاد مكانية.
أي جسم عنده 3 أبعاد مكانية،
أو أي موقع، ليس فقط الجسم.
هذا مكعب سميتهُ إس بي 1،
وأقصد بها سباشل أو سبيس،
أي المكان (الموقع).
مكعب له طول وعرض وارتفاع،
واستغرق مني الوقت الذي أريده.
هذا المكعب الذي رأيناه منذ قليل،
إذا قمنا بطي أبعاده.
العرض والطول والارتفاع.
أي صنعنا بعدًا مكانيًا.
سميناه بعدًا مكانيا وأعطيناه
إحداثيه صادية
[المحور ص].
الزمن T1 هو البعد الرابع.
و المساحة الموجودة هي كل أنشطتنا.
نحن عالم ذو بعدين اسمه الزمكان.
عالمنا كله ذو بعدين، لا أكتر.
كل هذه الأنشطة الملونة التي تلاحظونها.
لا على التعيين
لكن الخاصية التى يجب الانتباه إليها
أنها باتجاه واحد.
لا تسير عكس الزمن وليست أيضا عمودية.
لا يوجد توقف زمني.
تلاحظ أنها كلها تتجه نحو اليسار؛
إلى الاتجاه الزمني.
كلها تتجه إلى الاتجاه الموجب.
الآن،
لو افترضنا أننا أحذنا البعد الزمني التاني
الذي رمزنا له بالبعد الخامس،
وقلنا أيضا أنه يتقاطع مع البعد الرابع
أي أنه صار عندنا حجم من ثلاثة أبعاد
البعد الزمني الرابع، والبعد المكاني،
والبعد الخامس.
صار عندنا سطح الزمكان - المستوى العميق -
الذي يمثل أنشطتنا التقليدية.
في حين أنه بالأسفل
يوجد إحداثيين زمنيين رئيسيين
والسطح ذو اللون الأصفرعلى اليسار
هو البعد السباشال؛
أي المكان مع البعد الخامس.
في كل هذه المستويات توجد حياة.
فلنطبق إحدى ظواهر الباراسيكولوجي
التي ذكرناها في البداية.
وكلكم حدث عندكم هذا الأمر
كأن تأتي إلى مكان - جاليرى مثلا -
وتقول لنفسك "لقد جئت هنا من قبل."
هل حدث هذا معكم أم لا؟
أتوقع أن يكون هذا موجود عندكم.
يأتى شخص إلى مكان ويقول
لقد جئت هنا من قبل.
يقال له متى جئت هنا؟
فيظل يفكر ويحاول أن يتذكر فلا يصل لشيء.
أو كما قلنا من قبل. كأن يخطر على بالي
حسن مثلًا، الذى لم أره منذ ست سنوات.
وأجده بعد قليل يتصل على الهاتف.
أَتعجبُ كيف؟
إذًا ماذا يحدث، كيف نفسر ذلك؟
تستطيع أن تفسرها عن طريق الأبعاد
التي ذكرناها.
فلنلاحظ أن هناك
ما يسمى بالديجافو(Déjà vu).
وهذا المصطلح يعني الشعور
بحدث مرئي مسموع في السابق.
أي أنني رأيت مكان ما من قبل,
أو حدث متسلسل.
مثلا كأن تسقط سيجارة وبعدها يصرخ طفل
ثم تسمع جرس الباب.
ثم تقول لنفسك أن هذه الأحداث الثلاثة
المتسلسلة
حدثت من قبل بنفس ترتيبها.
وتحاول أن تتذكر متى فلا تتذكر.
ما الحل؟
الحل - بحسب ادعائي - هو عن طريق الأبعاد.
فلنلاحظ تلك الكرة فهي التي ستترجم لكم
كيفية حدوث ذلك.
لابد أن ننتبه أننا نتحدث
عن زمن في زمن.
في الحقيقة الزمن الأول
لا يمكن أن يرجع للخلف
لكنه يستند على الزمن الثاني.
كذلك الزمن الثاني أيضا لا يرجع
واتجاه الزمن الثاني إلينا.
فالزمن الرابع [الأول] متجه إلى جهة اليمين.
فالزمن الخامس [الثاني] يساعد الزمن الأول
دون أن يخل بالنظام.
فإذا لاحظت علامة ال X ستجدها
تنتهي إلى الأمام قليلا عن مكان توقفها.
وقد لا يجاوز ذلك 2 مللي من الثانية.
والمللي يساوي جزء من الألف من الثانية.
وقد يكون بالماكرو ثانية.
فلو لاحظنا سنجد أن السبب الحقيقي
هو ما يسمى بالطية الزمنية.
وكأن بصيرتنا تسبق الزمن ثم تعود مرة أخرى.
أو بالأحرى أنها تذهب لترى المستقبل جزئيا
ولو لجزء من الثانية ثم تعود.
وهذا الأمر يسمى بالطية الزمنية
Time Folding.
وهذا هو ال Time Folding
أن الكرة تتحرك من رقم 3
ثم تستمرحتى 2 مللى من الثانية
والأن أضائت عندما رأت صورة الجاليري
ثم عادت.
من الأفضل أن نجسم هذه الصورة
الأن، هذا رجل يقترب من الجاليري
و ذهنه أخذ نسخة من الجاليري
ثم رجع الزمن والرجل مستمر في المشي
ثم يتسائل .. ماهذا؟
أنا مؤكد أني جئت هنا من قبل.
هو لا يدرك أن ذهنه سبق وجوده في المكان
بأجزاء من الثانية
أي أنه وصل إلى المكان والتقط صورة له
ثم عاد إليه.
وكأنما دخلت الصورة عنده في اللاوعي
بدون إمضاءات أو تواقيع رسمية .
وهناك حالات كثير من الديجافو
تقع ضمن هذه الحالة
أشكركم جدا على حسن متابعتكم.
(تصفيق)